bonjour monsieur malgré eux alors sans
donner un cours de droit il y assure une
différence est qu'on peut expliquer
rapidement entre les deux instances je
pense qu'on en a une qui s'occupe des
disputes entre les pays c'est ça la cour
nationale de justice a compétence pour
les litiges entre états et la cour
pénale internationale pour poursuivre
des individus au criminel c'est à dire
pour vraiment dans une perspective
punitive bon alors là on a vu que
l'ukraine a déposé devant la cour
internationale de justice une requête
pour que cesse l'invasion de la russie
ça c'est un des uns des différents que
la cour pourrait régler oui tout à fait
ça ça arrivera pas tout de suite ça va
prendre quelques temps mais la cour peut
ordonner des mesures provisoires et
pourrait notamment assez vite
ordonné à la russie d'arrêter tout acte
de violence sur le territoire de
l'ukraine on imagine bien que la russie
va pas s'arrêter immédiatement mais
malgré tout ça pèse dans la gestion de
long terme du contentieux bon alors je
me demande quel pouvoir réel la cour
internationale de justice peut avoir
pour ordonner quoi que ce soit la russie
alors que la russie s'est même pas
présenté à la cour internationale de
justice lundi oui alors les états sont
pas obligés de se présenter c'est un
choix stratégique parfois il se présente
pas généralement ça se retourne contre
eux c'est pas idéal parce qu'ils peuvent
pas faire valoir leur point de vue la
russie elle reconnaît pleinement la
compétence de la cour internationale de
justice elle et quand sa justice est
l'organe judiciaire des nations unies
donc y'a rien de d'inattendu à la russie
est apparue par le passé dans des
affaires
y compris comme comme partie plaignante
donc
malgré tout effectivement alors la
russie a décidé de pas se faire
représenter en disant que les
allégations de l'ukraine était tellement
absurde que ça valait même pas la peine
d'envoyer une équipe de juristes on sait
pas si peut-être les juristes de moscou
ont eu un peu de mal à apprendre à
trouver un avion pour la haye mais en
tous les cas effectivement ils sont pas
du tout d'accord avec une craie d'un
come on peut imaginer
voilà bon parlons maintenant de la cour
pénale internationale parce que on sait
il ya un procureur qui a demandé de se
pencher sur les crimes contre l'humanité
les crimes de guerre hélas aujourd'hui
quand j'ai vu les bombardements d'un
hôpital pédiatrique je me dis mon dieu
mais ça répond exactement à cette
définition non tout à fait la russie est
dans une situation quand même assez
précaire puisque la cour pénale
internationale a compétence sur tout le
territoire de l'ukraine à la demande de
l'ukraine elle même et que donc c'est
une compétence qui s'exerce en continu
en temps réel si vous voulez donc le
procureur est
averti et il observe des violations des
conflits au delà du droit des conflits
armés au fur et à mesure qu'elles se
commettent donc c'est une situation
plutôt favorable à l'ukraine bien sûr il
faut faire attention entre ce qu'on voit
à la télévision est la preuve qu'un
crime de guerre a été commis et par
exemple c'est un accident pas juste un
missile qui seraient allés ailleurs que
là où il était censé aller ça va prendre
un peu plus de travail et de temps mais
on a énormément d'informations qui
remonte du terrain et là il faudra
accuser une personne où on peut accuser
le commun des armées ou celui qui tire
les missiles en question alors vous
savez plus on remonte dans la chaîne
hiérarchique plus est difficile à
prouver donc effectivement le risque est
toujours qu'on s'en prenne à des soldats
et pas à des officiers encore moins à
des généraux et encore moins à des
politiques malgré tout les tribunaux
pénaux internationaux pour l'ex
yougoslavie et pour le rwanda ont réussi
à obtenir des condamnations notamment
pour crimes contre l'humanité parce
qu'on sait bien que les politiques ont
souvent un rôle déterminant les
militaires sont souvent en partie des
exécutants de politiques qui sont
décidés à un plus haut niveau que et où
des décisions très des libérés sont
prises de s'en prendre aux civils non
mais on sait que tout ça ne se fera pas
rapidement d'abord il faut recueillir la
preuve et puis il faudra mettre ça en
oeuvre c'est pas ça sera pas vite oui
mais n'oublions pas que la compétence de
la cour pénale internationale à propos
du cred elle date de 2014 de l'incident
la crimée et que donc on a toutes les
raisons de penser que le procureur
travaillent sur ces dossiers déjà des
pme deux années alors je suis vraiment
désolé je dois vous interrompre en aura
assurément l'occasion de se reparler
merci beaucoup merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i see her dit
[Musique]